this is my happy place and it has been
for a long long time
it's the ferry that goes from my parents
house near manly beach to downtown
Sydney there's nothing magical about the
boat itself tourists and locals ride
this thing every day but really that's
what makes this very so special
no commuter ride on the planet offers up
more amazing city views it's routine
made spectacular
now you won't know it from my accent but
I spent a lot of time here as a kid my
Aussie grandfather helped build the
Sydney Harbour Bridge and my Aussie mum
helped build the Opera House I know I
know the goatee it was a phase cut me
some slack the point is I grew up eating
things like this and worshipping these
folks my hope is that the Aussie cred
will buy me some forgiveness for what
comes next
this country which punches far above its
weight in so many areas has
underachieved terribly when it comes to
technology for years talented Aussie
coders have escaped to Silicon Valley to
make their livings and recent Australian
government policies have underfunded
science and tech as my PAP would say
Ozzy Tec is crook
there are signs though that Australia
has turned on and started to retain some
of its homegrown tech talent this then
is an odyssey to find the country's
rising stars my journey goes from the
beaches of Sydney to the artsy
cosmopolitan streets of Melbourne along
the way I get lost in a cave with only
glowworms to guide me go diving in the
ocean with a robot and make friends with
some dinosaurs all in this episode of
hello world Silicon Valley may be home
to some of the biggest tech giants in
the world but it's being challenged like
never before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet making things that will
blow your mind my name is Ashley Vance
I'm an author and journalist and I'm on
a quest to find the most innovative tech
creations and meet the beautiful freaks
behind them
check any survey of the best places to
live and you'll find Sydney near the top
it's a sprawling gorgeous city of about
four million good spirited people who
love to be outdoors to party and to
enjoy life but there's a strong case to
be made that Sydneysiders may be too
content at least when it comes to the
city's taxi well big companies like
Google and Microsoft have offices here
Sydney can only point to a couple of
smash startups that have made it big
overseas that famous Aussie pluck has
gone missing
there is however a tech revolution
building and it's being led by young
ambitious scientists they've left their
fancy University labs and migrated to
Sydney's tech underground and no one
proves this point more than the free
radical I'll meet first okay
this spot doesn't exactly use tech it's
an artist warehouse in a Sydney suburb
but move deeper through the creative
commune and you'll find a makeshift side
slab and this guy one of its founders
the transhumanist
polyamorous biohacker you all know the
type
welcome to why foundry Australia's first
open access molecular biology lab
Sinister's it can sometimes sound
biohacking has turned into an exciting
new field its do-it-yourself
meddling with DNA on the cheap to tweak
nature and this is Australia's first
biohacker lab open to anyone willing to
pay a membership fee let's get into it
in the name of this biohacking pioneer
meow meow do you prefer to be a mr. meow
mr. meow now meows meows fine meow hit
up generous friends for a lot of the
scientific gear and he hopes the lab
will inspire people of all stripes to
give biotech a try it's about pulling
people in with hands-on experiments like
extracting DNA from the strawberry if
you stir or where the alcohol touches
the strawberries you be able to pull out
some stringy stuff and that's the DNA so
that's the instructions to make a
strawberry this is the first step in a
bio hack lab pretty much anything we're
doing with molecular biology we're gonna
need to get that DNA out the flavor
genes the pigment genes we can take
these genes out and put them in other
things so you might want to make an
apple that tastes like a strawberry you
might be able to take the pigment genes
out make a new type of paint so you kind
of take the most interesting properties
of some organism extract it out and then
maybe chuck it into something else and
give it some new superpowers and that's
it yeah nice everything blar the
molecular biologist by training Miao has
put the lab to work on real projects
ranging from auntie mold paint and take
home STD tests to phosphorescent alcohol
cool damn straight it is
now insisted that my next tutorial take
place in nature we set out for the
newness State Forest located in the
famed Blue Mountains about five hours
west of Sydney it's there that we hope
to find the tiny creature at the heart
of Meow's make everything feel like a
rave dreams
sorry we're about to go to the glowworm
tunnel it used to be a railway tunnel
they used in mining and now it's been a
decommissioned and the glowworms have
come back and Riaan habited the tunnel
I've waited this long and now I have to
ask you how did you get the name yeah
yeah I'd want to change my name since I
was like 15 my friends and I just sat
down and we just wrote down a huge list
of names and then we pick the one that
sounded the best what's your full name
now now Ludo disco camera meow meow with
the formalities out of the way the time
had come to meet one of Australia's
lesser known biological attractions
glowworms a nocturnal they are generally
less sensitive to red wavelengths of
light than they are white or blue light
I guess to see them best we've got to
turn this off now talks a lot about a
lot of things sometimes he's hyping a
mango that's been altered to do your
laundry and other times he's promoting
hallucinogen aided orgies to each his
own but without question
meows biohacking enthusiasm has worked
with labs modeled on this spot popping
up all around the country
prepare yourself Australia for the
phosphorescent revolution has begun up
next I head from the mountains back to
Sydney's beautiful beaches for a good
old-fashioned swim with an underwater
drone my vision would be to make the
underwater more accessible to people and
eventually maybe even living underwater
I would love to do that
San Francisco is nice at all but if
you're a techie looking for somewhere
good to live why not pick this it's not
cold and foggy with rivers of urine
cascading down hilly streets its
sunshine and beaches real amazing
beaches intertwined throughout Sydney
suburbs and just about everyone at the
beaches is beautiful because the Sharks
only eat the ugly paint
some Aussies are even lucky enough to
work out here and that's why I've turned
up in the eastern suburbs of Sydney at
Clovelly Beach to meet with the company
called abyss solutions I just had this
gut feeling that you know this is where
things are gonna be going the underwater
world hasn't been explored and
exploration is my passion the best
solutions is a young startup founded in
2014 by a mix of australians and
immigrants the company's CEO Nasir asan
grew up in Pakistan and his co-founder
Massoud Naqshbandi came from Afghanistan
together the young men have advanced
degrees in fields like machine learning
and material science now they're looking
to combine the latest in underwater
drones mapping software and data
analysis hoping to learn more about
bodies of water huge progress has been
made already with this type of drone
technology when it comes to analyzing
the earth the work being done by abyss
though March the first stage of a
similar undersea journey this is an
aquatic drone this has got 100 meter
depth rating yeah there's a battery
chambers pan tilt zoom camera so you can
move up and down it's got a bunch of
lasers
when I think of like you see Jacques
Cousteau or whoever leaked like
exploring underwater I mean it's like
some crazy submarine contraption or it's
these divers yeah staying on it for a
long time it seemed like this would be a
low-cost way to do a lot of that type
work there's a human cost of it as well
because these divers when they're going
to work they're going to really
dangerous environments like sometimes
they go into sewage elegans which is
really nasty and it smells and horrible
and then really put their lives at risk
so this is a perfect example of robotic
solutions where a simple robot can do
the job just equally as well well the
electronics are relatively
straightforward the software needed to
clean up images analyze surfaces and map
otherwise invisible terrain proves
tricky to build the key to a business
technology is the way in which they
blend thousands of images together and
then precisely spot something like a
crack in a bridge you can see like 3d
models of the ship hall or the dam wall
so we can say hey at this location
there's a little crack in the hall the
abyss engineers have to direct the drone
today next up they want to make it fully
autonomous and rig the device with a
bevy of sensors deep-sea is a bit away
but that's what I'm really interested in
that's where my passion is I want to be
able to develop sensors that will help
us explore the ocean my vision would be
you know beyond robotics to make the
underwater world more accessible to
people and eventually maybe even living
underwater you know possibilities are
endless are you gonna live underwater I
would love to do that
the bise's received help from tech
incubators funded by local companies and
universities which is an example of
Australia starting to mimic Silicon
Valley in a successful way with a bit of
luck and some more hard work Aquaman
over here may soon get to live out his
dreams as you can tell I'm not one of
those six pack AB types of Australians
so after a long day of getting skin
cancer with robots
I needed to cool off with a snack there
you go oh man thanks for watch for Megan
okay give it a go this is um chocolate
hazelnut creme brulee okay give it a
break it's got the crunchy top Wow
it's delicious given that this is a tech
show I couldn't go to any old ice cream
shop
I'm a 10-2 extreme gelato whereas our
more savvy viewers will already have
figured out they use liquid nitrogen to
freeze their sweet sweet cream
is there a reason for using nitric
Island a lot of people think is just for
show but it's not it gives us a
flexibility make our gelato fresh so
instead of having your gelato sitting in
a freezer for don't know however long
you can make it fresh on order making it
this way means that we can control the
temperature we serve it to you ad so
what you're having here is actually very
warm you're looking at minus six minus
eight degrees Celsius which means that
your palate can taste the flavor better
whereas if you take say an ice cream or
gelato Alfa freezer you're talking about
minus eighteen your tongue receptors are
not able to get the flavors as how it
should be pumped full of nitrogen it was
time to leave Sydney and head south to
the bustling city of Melbourne Melbourne
lacks the surf culture of Sydney but has
plenty going on in a sport mad country
Melbourne is considered the athletic
capital thanks to its massive venues for
cricket rugby and tennis it's also
something of a cultural capital the
elegant city gives off a European charm
if it's huge Greek and Italian
communities a tram system and it takes
great pride in its lane ways which are
alleys packed full of street graffiti
and world-class restaurants one after
the end if you're looking to eat your
way through Australia this is a good
place to start the artsy up-and-comer
vibe - Melbourne has had an impact on
its tech scene people here have needed
to think a bit different to get
attention and it's paid off there's an
argument to be made that Melbourne may
be Australia's most promising tech hub
at least in terms of raw creativity
the undisputed king of melbourne taxine
bears this thesis out he's Ruslan Kogan
the founder and CEO of Cogan calm an
online retailer that has changed the way
Australian shop we do about three times
more revenue per employee than Amazon
he's a rich flamboyant controversial
workaholic who finds an escape now and
again at the Melbourne pier alright
let's go catch some snapper okay you
must have been around like eight years
old when you moved here from from
Belarus or six years old
communism is falling apart my parents
decided to leave which I'm so thankful
for and came here with $90 in their
pockets kögel grew up in melbourne
housing projects and showed an
entrepreneur spirit right from the stone
as a kid he ran a golf ball cleaning
business a car wash and then a tech
consulting operation by the time he was
23
Kogan had become consumed with another
quest man's eternal hunt for an
affordable flat screen TV I thought you
know I can't afford it from the shops
but let me email some factories and I
thought I'd tell them that I want to
order a hundred thousand TVs and they'll
get back to me and then I'll ask for a
sample and that sample was going to be
my TV but when they started replying
with all of their quotes I saw very
quickly that there's a brilliant market
opportunity here the big idea Cogan hit
on was to go direct to Chinese
manufacturers to buy TVs for a fraction
of the going price to get the first
batch of TVs Kogan maxed out a few
credit cards and had to borrow money
from his friends you're on this leg to
just get a cheap TV and it turns into a
business idea yeah
Australians had been slow to hop online
and local retailers had largely ignored
the web Kogan dragged the entire country
online and helped ignite an Internet
retail boom today
Kogan sells about 250 million dollars of
products per year and rustling wants to
expand the brand overseas and make Kogan
a household name sure a check if we
still have a let's have a look yeah not
a single bot what do you think should we
keep trying or should we drink beer
thanks man you people keep telling me
they feel like Australia was a little
bit late to protect us this but now it's
turning this corner you're kind of
famous for being outspoken and telling
the truth on things you know I can't
tell if I'm getting spun or if they're
really as good of a quarter B
turn look we went through a time in
Australia where our business leaders and
politicians we're talking about how bad
online retail is because it's going to
it's going to cost a lot of jobs in the
retail industry
I'm surprised they've already stopped
talking about how bad cars are because
everybody who used to make false
carriages has gone out of business
luckily we're at a point now where
they're starting to realize that
innovation is the future there's only a
certain amount of stuff you can dig out
of the ground our brainpower and our
ideas are an unlimited resource and if
you can harness that one then you're
going to be a very rich nation up next I
meet with some other Melbourne locals do
also think different and have their own
takes on what's next
protect our underneath
if you're a hip city on the move what
you need is a giant Ferris wheel the
Melbourne star opened in 2008 and is
said to be the southern hemisphere's
only giant observation wheel whatever
that means
as far as big technology and big science
goes Melbourne can lay claim to some
stunning achievements scientists here
did pioneering work on in-vitro
fertilisation heart valve replacement
and cochlear implants and the big
science journey into our bodies
continues on at a place known as the
Australian synchrotron the synchrotron
cost 150 million dollars to build and
opened in 2007 in this Melbourne suburb
the building basically functions like a
giant x-ray machine slash microscope it
propels electrons at incredible speeds
and that manipulates them with magnetic
fields to produce a brilliant form of
light known a synchrotron light
this light can end up being a million
times brighter than the Sun and can be
tweaked by the building to peer into a
wide variety of objects so far the
synchrotron has been used to examine
plants and animals in fine detail and to
peer through the layers of objects like
old paintings soon it may be used to
treat diseases to get Andrew actually
how you doing nice to meet you nice to
meet ed repeal is a physicist and the
director of the synchrotron he agreed to
give me what's known as the Greg Norman
tour of the place that's a sweet ride
come aboard they do some of these beam
lines that were driving past there are
researchers using these to do things
like trying to cure cancer different
forms of disease a lot of it's a bit
like imagining a lock and a key if you
can understand which locks fit which
keys you can turn diseases on and off
you can stop cancer in its tracks recent
anti science Australian governments have
threatened to slash funding for labs
like this as a result many top
scientists have left the country but in
2015 the synchrotron lucked out and
receive 500 million dollars in funding
over the next 10 years the hope is that
this facility can make money on its own
by doing commercial work yay science to
get a closer look at this machine while
avoiding having my guts burned away
hello Daniel
hello I spoke with Daniel Houser me a
scientist here who's looking at how the
synchrotron can diagnose and treat
cancer we use x-ray beam that are
billion times brighter then you would in
the hospital so in those people he's
safe you put your chest in a second you
get a chest x-ray if you do a second
without beam here you burn
you could smoke there's a hole in your
chest because of its unique construction
the Australian synchrotron can make
large beams 50 centimeters wide
or about the width of a human body this
means that the machine could be ideal
for turbocharged radiotherapy of tumors
we found that you can deliver doses
which are a thousand times higher for
more targeted more targeted and less
damage to the healthy tissues okay so
you could say that thousand gray would
kill a human being if it was delivered
in a single shot broad area when you
make it in micro beams it doesn't it
actually destroy tumors much better and
spares healthy tissue
it's not ready for human trials yet but
Daniel thinks people may soon be able to
make an appointment and have this
building go to work on your innards
it will be several years before we can
apply to actually a patient therefore
that the caveat is anyone watches your
show and then call us and say you I want
to bring you my granddad because they
can treat these cancer unfortunately
with size sorry we can't do it right now
for maybe one day but maybe in three or
five years yeah these optimistic notes
reflect just how hard Australian
scientists must work these days to
justify their jobs and provide the
government with the
it's that these types of facilities may
one day pay for themselves
but you know it's more fun than
anti-science bureaucrats that would be
dinosaurs
welcome to Jurassic warehouse this is
stegosaur stegosaur is for a jurassic
world exhibition this is our t-rex she
tends to steal the show and dominate the
workshop I can't think one of these
things is gonna eat me yeah Sonny
Childers hails from Melbourne and
co-founded creature technology since its
birth in 2006 the company is specialized
in making giant robotic animals and has
ended up as one of the biggest
animatronics companies around the
creature team is made up of movies
special effects artists who needed work
during down periods and their first
project was a live show called Walking
with Dinosaurs that ended up as the
highest-grossing touring event in the
world in 2010
they've been on high demand ever since
making rideable dragons a full-size King
Kong and cuddlier creations like these
giant stuffed animals for the Sochi
Olympics Vladimir Putin still likes to
cuddle the bunny rabbit on the right we
didn't know where this is gonna go we
thought we'd all go back to filming TV
but it grew out of this one show and we
realized that there was something in
this to bring that sort of film level
animatronics to a live audience
this is the indominus rex at the moment
where I'm skinning the creature and the
girls are putting in some scales each
one of these creatures takes about a
year to create every detail of the
anatomy is built from scratch including
the eyeballs the hydraulic skeleton and
the life like fabric skin so it's very
similar to a real creature it's got
bones he's got muscles that's got skin
until they work together is it's the
trick really to make the creatures seem
more lifelike the company's coders
program nuanced movement routines
but I'm not here to watch a computer
play with Dinosaurs I'm here to take a
dino out for a spin so this is a Buddha
wreak
so I'm actually controlling the neck of
this Parasaurolophus now so this is all
homegrown it's a like that yeah I mean
we built these for our first live show
ten years ago and this is our rusty
workshop model
whenever go yes okay he is designed to
be intuitive and smooth and so you can
take him through his whole range and he
will go where you want to take him have
your little pet dinosaur yeah it's a lot
of fun there were a couple of new
creations coming to life in the creature
workshop that we weren't allowed to show
you secrecy remains paramount in the
vicious world of animatronics it's safe
to say though that the next time a
dinosaur giant plush bear or say an
alien creature at an amusement park then
it came from this place on the other
side of the world
Australia's done well for itself in
recent years its minds have churned out
natural resources that China has
welcomed with open wallets there's the
whole awkward thing and the local soap
operas have kept the rest of the world
well-stocked with attractive
entertainers as protect it remains a
mixed story meow meow for example has
decided to form a start-up in San
Francisco because it proved easier to
raise money there
that said Australia still teams with
well educated and motivated engineers
coders and scientists there are plenty
of success stories now for these
youngsters to follow there's also an
undeniable urge for Australians to make
a go of it at home and prove what
they're capable of
and if you fail the worst thing that can
happen is that you end up here looking
for another dash of courage in a beer
coming up next on hello world I head to
England to learn about the start of the
computing revolution freedom to every
watch of the world and to get all
gussied up with the world's most
advanced hair dryer